so ahead of cop 26 which we've heard
about on this and most other editions of
our show there's another big u.n
conference taking place cop 15 on
biodiversity is hosted by china and is
taking place virtually now world leaders
are discussing how to protect and slow
the loss of nature
it's widely believed that climate change
is a primary driver for biodiversity
loss so how important is it that we
tackle the two issues together cece i'll
put that to you
first of all what is the link between
biodiversity and climate change and does
it make sense to you that they're dealt
with together
um thank you for having me um so
biodiversity is closely linked to
climate change in two ways number one
that climate change um reduces
biodiversity and this is because
temperature rises are now means that
plants and animals are struggling to
survive and the second way in which like
climate change is linked to biodiversity
is that biodiversity acts as a mitigator
for climate change so essentially um
biodiversity means more plants and these
plants suck up emissions like a vacuum
cleaner in essence so
they help mitigate the climate crisis so
that's those are the sort of linkages
so so richard important that countries
with less money are helped to try and
protect their biodiversity and we have
heard haven't we that china's pledged a
230 million dollars for a new
biodiversity fund did that surprise you
that move
not particularly because i think china
is very keen to make a success of this
in terms of the amount of money it is
really a drop in the ocean though i
covered when i was a journalist 10 years
ago the last really big biodiversity
summit in in japan at that stage the sum
of money that were being talked about to
basically halt the global loss of
biodiversity was about 100 billion
dollars a year so we're some way short
of this but a very very long way short
of this um i think it there's an it does
um raise an interesting point because in
the climate change arena the
international agreements basically
specify that all the money that helps
the developing countries has to come
from the traditionally rich nations from
europe and north america and australia
and japan and so on so by china putting
this forward we may be you know seeing
that the the start of a discussion about
whether some of the newly enriching
nations china saudi arabia qatar some of
the others actually should be putting
their hands in their pockets also for
climate change damages well yes and on
that subject of climate finance cc
there's been a big debate about
why the money hasn't been forthcoming
quickly enough i mean is there enough
money going towards biodiversity or is
it seen as the poor relation somehow
yeah i think money is um is very
important and um there needs to be more
um but i really think the issue here is
um in terms of our diversity and climate
change is that we do not we have not
really linked um human activities with
biodiversity and by that i mean that
basically human activities are the key
drivers to biodiversity loss but we
don't really know exactly how our
investment decisions or business
decisions are actually having a proper
outcome on biodiversity so um i would
like to highlight a
ways that in which that we can make that
link and one example is a eu regulation
which is called the eu taxonomy
regulation act which was brought in last
year but basically what they do is that
they link economic activities with um
proper
biodiversity outcomes so if you're an
investor if you're business people you
are going to you know invest in a place
where there is biodiversity problems you
wouldn't know so this is the kind of
mechanisms that we need
in developing countries to really help
them with the decision making process in
addition to financial
support
you